en el cementerio de el espinar se abre
una fosa común y se cierra una herida
rosamaria recupera los restos de su
padre eugenio insúa asesinado por los
militares franquistas y hasta ahora uno
de los más de 100.000 desaparecidos
durante la guerra civil y la dictadura y
muy conmovida por todo lo que está
pasando
teníamos la necesidad de poder dar con
él de no dejarle en el olvido porque
esto sí que cierra heridas nosotros
hemos recuperar mi abuelo pero sigue
habiendo mucha gente no en esta fosa en
un montón de fosas a lo largo de todo
españa hay alrededor de tres mil fosas
comunes en el país con la nueva ley de
memoria democrática el estado quiere
asumir las exhumaciones y crear un banco
de adn de los cuerpos a una bolsa
hasta ahora el trabajo lo asumen
voluntarios como los de la asociación
por la recuperación de la memoria
histórica que desde hace décadas luchan
por esclarecer los crímenes de la época
más oscura de españa'
boca abajo
y negros entre cruzados entre sí con
signos de fracturas de violencia cosas
usuales de ver dentro de unas cosas
la transición democrática se basó en un
ejercicio de olvido colectivo algo que
pretende cambiar la nueva legislación
para evitar la repetición del pasado
pero de hecho los crímenes del
franquismo se investigan en argentina
gracias a la iniciativa de esta
asociación ya que en españa el proceso
choca con la ley de amnistía de 1977
incluida la fiscalía que pretende crear
el gobierno con la ley de la memoria que
no va a tener ninguna utilidad si no se
deroga la ley de amnistía es además una
deuda que tiene el estado para todos
aquellos que murieron tras 45 años de la
muerte del dictador se prohibirá la
exaltación del franquismo y asoma el
proceso de verdad justicia y reparación